hey gang dave baker here and today we're
going to go over some of my favorite
curved weapons featured on fortune fire
curved weapons are often associated with
horse cultures the long curvature of the
blade gives an extra cutting circle but
that blade's also been adapted by
infantries around the world so let's
take a look at some of my favorite
curved weapons from forged and fire
the katana
built in response to the mongol invasion
of japan smithson japan figured out new
ways to forge high carbon steel with a
soft core to make a blade that was both
resilient flexible and deadly let's put
it to the test
nice
the katana was often worn with the curve
up that way when a warrior drew his
sword he could draw and cut in one
motion
i think
this will kill the katana might be the
most iconic bladed weapon today because
of its use in film and television
it's definitely a fan favorite
the core is the traditional weapon of
the gurkha people of nepal and northern
india usually in all steel construction
decorah has a wide spatulated tip with a
sharp curved inward edge and usually
round disc pommel and guard the core was
designed for chopping and slashing and
with that large forward curve
and the spatulated head
it put the weight way forward of the
center that way the impact of the chop
is all up here
a devastating cutter wow pretty much
took care of that skull
it's a beast i don't know about you but
if i saw someone coming at me with this
i'd probably take up archery
run fire is a weapon of the thracian
people and was adapted from the actual
agricultural sickle but unlike a sickle
the blade's been straightened out giving
it the ability to both thrust
and cut
two hands
give you a lot of power and a lot of
grip
[Music]
now not much is known historically about
these weapons other than anecdotal
evidence
this is a stout weapon
with his long blade and its long handle
was nearly a pole arm with the reach it
gave a warrior
the tawar is the traditional weapon of
the rajput a political dynasty that came
to power in the seventh century
the toward hilt was often decorated with
inlay and carving
but for the average warrior a good
sturdy iron hill was all they needed it
consisted of an all steel handle
ring pummel with a knuckle bow and small
guard though the tillwater looks heavy
it's actually an incredibly maneuverable
fast light weapon
i just love sabers
now the word hussar is a hungarian word
describing a type of light cavalry
what made the hussar so devastating was
their training and their discipline in
battle
famous groups of hussars existed from
the polish winged hussars
to napoleon sousars
to the famous hungarian cavalry
and all of them use a curved saber like
this curvesaber gives you the advantage
of a long slicing cut that can be used
on either side of the horse's neck
forward back
cutting thrusting
and the hands of an expert
it's a deadly weapon
though the saver dominated the
battlefield for a number of years with
the advent of cartridge ammunition it
went the way of armor
you